because like i think one of the craziest
like weather phenomena i've been caught
up in was uh when i was in vegas and
they have dust storms there
dust storms yeah so basically just think
of a sandstorm but instead of the sand
coming in from i've never even been in
the sandstorm right well i haven't been
in a sandstorm but i've been in a dust
storm and it happens pretty frequently
the difference between sand and dust uh
i i don't i i thought it was a sand
storm at first right but then everyone
all my friends were like oh it's a dust
storm coming and it's like a different
vernacular maybe or it's like maybe it's
not just sand maybe it's like sand and
other crap like mixed into it but
basically i was like i i was driving
around in uh in vegas you know just with
with a bunch of friends and then like on
the radio because he had the radio on he
just like suddenly switches on and he's
like oh there's a dust storming coming
um so please you know please evacuate
kind of thing and i was [ __ ] my
pants i was like what the [ __ ] is a dust
storm
and then uh but everyone else there the
locals just like oh yeah it happens
pretty frequently let's let's just go to
like a restaurant get something to eat
so uh so we we go into this restaurant
and then the dust storm hits and it's
like just yeah just think of like a
typhoon right so it's like just really
insane winds
but
you can't see outside like the whole
windows are like like nothing it's just
like all sand it's just like like it's
like a blizzard but instead of white
it's just like grayish brown it's like a
survival game yeah but what's more
terrifying in my opinion than a blizzard
is the fact that uh in a dust storm it
can cause static electricity oh so
basically you have like thunder strikes
at ground level
because of all the particles rubbing
together right so every now and then
it'll just be like blowing and then
you'll just hear this like boom sound
from outside and i'm like the [ __ ] is
happening it's like oh that's just the
electricity
it's like why are you saying it like oh
yeah yeah that's just my friend
like you know like saying it so casually
yeah um
yeah so it's very interesting yeah so
that entire time i was [ __ ] my pants
while we were in this uh
we're in this ramen shop because of
course they were like oh joe's japanese
let's just go to a japanese restaurant
i'm like yeah
yeah i'm here all the way in vegas to go
eat some japanese subpar japanese food
all right bed so
we were so basically i was stuck inside
a ramen shop called naruto are you
serious i'm not even fronting it was it
was called naruto they have like naruto
like uh i mean
and the ramen it was very obvious they
tried to replicate the naruto ramen as
best as they could
right you know to to
not that great levels admittedly i think
it was the most three out of 10 ramen
i've ever had so i was like great i'm
stuck inside this [ __ ] restaurant
called naruto eating up this poor
restaurant getting destroyed i don't
think it exists anymore yeah so someone
if it does exist sorry
you're just the most perfect moment of
like the locals going this guy's
japanese he likes anime so i got the
perfect one yeah that's the episode and
simpsons when they go to america town in
japan yeah
yeah basically
dude i mean the first thing the first
thing i ate when i went to america for
the first time which was the first ax i
ever went to my friends [ __ ] took me
to little tokyo and i was like bro yeah
everybody yeah every time you i've gone
to ax everyone's got a little turkey i
just came
and then i had again some subpar ramen
and a little tokyo i was like yeah great
the fan this is the la experience i
wanted the only time i've ever seen a
natural phenomenon of what uh i saw sun
in the uk one time
you were like oh i was like what the
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] i've seen fire tornadoes in
australia what the [ __ ] is a fire truck
we have bricks it is in the uk
so you have tornadoes yeah and you have
bush fires yeah so what happens when a
tornado enters a bushfire
you basically get this spiraling like
pillar of fire that's it
it's [ __ ]
awesome to look at from a distance
these like us settlers must have been so
[ __ ] confused when all this [ __ ] was
happening they were like what the [ __ ]
is happening i'm pretty sure that's what
the british saw the first time yeah
what the [ __ ] is that
the first time they found like the swamp
in florida they're like what yeah it's
like
a bit humid in here
like australia is just like a real life
island in one piece
it is an island on the ground line at
this point you know because like the
survival instincts you need in this
island like that that's taking out most
of the [ __ ] pirates in one piece at
this point imagine being the guy who is
to like write the guide they send back
so like people are going to come again
it's like so so by the way you're not
going to believe this right you know how
it's sun sometimes right yeah it's like
that all the time all the time and
sometimes i don't know how this happened
it was just by a tornado i don't know
what a tornado is we never seen one of
those yeah this is a tornado
it says but it's such a weird thing as
well because it's not like uh i i kind
of described it like there's a bush fire
and then a tornado comes along and like
eats up the fire it's also like the fire
is so strong that it basically creates
an up current that starts to spin and
then it just creates like this pillar of
fire
that just like crashes through it's just
really cool to see it just sounds like a
[ __ ] anime attack at this point
like well like like i was like i was
like is there a pokemon battle happening
over there and like someone did firespin
i don't know like it's like two jutsu's
being combined together in naruto you
know it's like
stomach after having that inherited
ramen
yeah i mean i did i did see actually
there recently like the uk or at least
london went through like a pretty bad
storm
yeah yeah um which i'd like i don't know
how bad it was because like when i when
i see i want to see like uk really bad
it looks really bad because like when i
see but like what you know when you see
uk headlines yeah you see like oh uk go
through like a bad storm like the
strongest wind scene and i'm just like
well is it like obviously it's going to
be bad for the uk but like how bad is it
on a global scale there is videos of it
picking up people and throwing them oh
seriously yeah yeah
yeah because when i saw that headline i
thought it was just like the british
over exaggerating it no dude you guys
usually just like oh my my friend's
toupee fell off it's an absolute
travesty like
it's so strong
i saw some videos people get thrown
around i was like oh my god
like like rip if you're trying to open
that car door man yeah yeah trying to
get that close
yeah because like this okay so like this
just shows how unused we are to this
these kind of like weather systems and
weather phenomena right because like we
um we're like me and connor in like a
group chat of like our friends back in
the uk um and sometimes you know they're
still meeting up and they're still
planning meetups and everything like
that and i saw in this group chat that
they had planned a meet up or to hang
out on this day and i remember like
right up to like the last moment people
were just like oh yeah i'll see you guys
in an hour i'll see you guys now right
we're still meeting in an hour and
people like yeah yeah i'll see you in an
hour and then you just see you just see
this the replies going
yeah let's maybe not meet up today maybe
that's not the best idea but like the
thing is if this was like one of the
worst storms that uk has gone has gone
through like i'm i am also really used
to the idea that no matter what
you can still go out and have a pipe
yeah you can still go out and have a
point no matter what yeah the pub has
been canceled so like that's how i knew
that this storm was like the real deal
yeah if my mates were not going to the
pub to meet up because of this storm you
know shit's gone down if the pub isn't
closed then that means i can still go
no matter what
it is basically that
[Laughter]
oh god yeah that is uh another episode
of uh uk people and
severely unprepared for you know weather
systems yeah because like i remember
you know when i first met my first like
you know british person like from the uk
yeah exist yeah i was like oh my god you
guys exist but second of all you know
they're always like oh yeah we have
nothing going on in the uk like no bad
weather no like dangerous animals no
nothing i'm like really like really like
i i found that hard to believe as
someone who came from the polar opposite
of that yeah from doom just college yeah
i came from doom i came from hell
basically
the underworld
yeah because it's like do you guys
really not like what is the most like
dangerous thing floods okay yeah i was
about to say we got a lot of rivers so
obviously when it rains a lot it can
flood but yeah depends on what depending
on where you are in the uk there aren't
floods like yeah like what if you're
like nowhere near like the rivers yeah
then you don't get anything
occasionally you guys get lucky yeah
yeah we've had hurricane scares before
at least in my lifetime but nothing that
actually like manifested anything felt
like a hurricane right yeah it was just
a bit of strong wind yeah yeah of gust
yeah that's that was pretty much it yeah
i mean we don't have a lot to fear in
the uk which is why whenever i travel
abroad
um whenever i well sorry i lost my train
of thought uh whenever i travel aboard
all
uh
whenever i travel abroad i got it i got
it this time
sometimes it just like surprises me um
about some of the things you have to be
careful of just because in the uk we
don't have to be careful of anything
like you know with camping you have to
be careful about bears or you know
starting a forest fire which to me like
starting a forest fire was like so
outside my perception of walk
of like disasters that could happen just
like one person but like
if you think about it yeah of course it
makes sense you know you see you look at
australia being on fire california like
half the year being on fire yeah like
our country was on fire for nine months
straight because of one guy starting a
fire yeah yeah yeah to me like that just
like that's just so outside of my
perception of what could [ __ ]
possibly go wrong of one like one stupid
person doing like a stupid thing you
know yeah so yeah i mean all the trees
are like wet in the uk it was very hard
to
get even i remember when we were camping
it was even hard to get like trees that
weren't too damp
to burn geez yeah i mean you could you
could come in with like a [ __ ]
flamethrower and it'll probably be put
out by the day the flamethrower will run
out of gas
[Laughter]
yeah i've ever seen anywhere like in
nature on fire in the uk really
no fire's just not like hard to get
started yeah yeah it's very hard to get
nature fires aren't like a thing that we
have to be careful about and yeah one of
the biggest uk hits was fire starter so
you know that's okay is
they had so much time while they were
making the fire starter yeah yeah um
yeah part of yourself
that's why it's an achievement right
yeah like it's easy to be a fire starter
anywhere else in the world in the uk
it's it's a medal i'm a fire star i was
like damn
did he manage that